Hallöchen ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute eine türkische Hackfleisch-Lauch Pfanne.
Ihr könnt dazu dann gerne Reis servieren oder nur Joghurt
oder ihr esst das mit Brot, auch sehr lecker.
Auf jeden Fall mag ich's richtig gerne weil es geht schnell und es schmeckt total lecker.
Ich hab jetzt hier meine Pfanne, erhitze da etwas Öl,
die genauen Mengenangaben, die Zutaten, alles, was ihr wissen müsst, schreib ich
immer in die Videobeschreibung. Findet ihr unterm Titel.
Könnt ihr euch direkt nen Screenshot machen und einkaufen gehen.
So, einmal das Öl erhitzen und jetzt nehm ich mir meine Knoblauchpresse
und presse da direkt Knoblauch rein.
Ihr wisst ja: türkische Gerichte, da darf kein Knoblauch fehlen!
Und das wird dann so ungefähr ½min angedünstet.
So und jetzt schnappt ihr euch Rinderhackfleisch und bratet das krümelig,
das heißt auf einer der höheren Stufen, also bei hoher Hitze
ungefähr 3min lang unter ständigem Rühren und wenden einmal anbraten.
Jetzt hab ich hier Paprikamark, auch typisch türkisch!
Ihr könntet auch Tomatenmark nehmen. Das geb ich mir dazu und arbeite das ein wenig ein,
das dauert nur ein paar Sekunden.
Und anschließend kommt schon unser Lauch bzw. Porree (ist ja eigentlich ein Synonym)
kommt schon zum Einsatz zusammen mit einer roten Spitzpaprika.
Das geb ich jetzt auch dazu und dann lass ich das so dünsten.
Ich geh niedriger mit der Stufe und das dauert dann ungefähr 2-3min.
Das ist halt eher beim Kochen so ne Gefühlssache.
So ihr Lieben! Jetzt kommen die Gewürze dazu. Salz und Pfeffer sind ganz klar,
das mach ich jetzt auch als allererstes. Also Salz und Pfeffer, ich mag's am liebsten frisch gemahlen.
Ich finde das schmeckt man einfach raus! Und dann ist ganz wichtig: Kreuzkümmel!
Gemahlenen Kreuzkümmel, den geb ich jetzt direkt dazu und ich geiz da auch nicht
weil Kreuzkümmel und Hackfleisch, also Fleisch generell Rind passt-
(H: Beste Kombi!)
Ja, beste Kombi! Direkt dazugeben. Dann Muskatnuss ist so ein Muss für unseren Lauch.
Also Muskatnuss und Lauch passen optimal zusammen.
Nicht zu viel, nur so ein bisschen! Und jetzt hab ich hier Paprikaflocken.
Das gibt's ja einmal die süße und die scharfe Variante. Hamza und ich mögen's nicht so scharf, ne?
Wir lassen das lieber!
(H: Pul biber!)
Pul biber! Super, schon Türkisch gelernt!
(H: Ja klar!)
So, dann geb ich jetzt von der süßen Variante ganz viel dazu und von der scharfen, ja nur so ein bisschen!
(H: Lass ein bisschen reinmachen!)
Nur so ein bisschen! So!
Und jetzt rühr ich das um. Ja und dann ist es im Prinzip schon fertig
aber es muss ja noch ein bisschen cremiger sein.
Jetzt habt ihr die Wahl: Macht ihr Sahne rein? Kein Problem, ein bisschen Sahne
bis es schön sämig wird oder Creme fraiche oder saure Sahne, das ist ein bisschen kalorienärmer
oder etwas passierte Tomaten könnt ihr auch gerne dazugeben.
Ich entscheid das jetzt ganz spontan. Ihr seht's dann in der nächsten Szene!
Wir nehmen heute die Tomatenvariante. Einverstanden Hamza?
(H: Ja! Tomate geht immer.)
Genau! Aber auch nur ein bisschen, es soll ja nicht zu flüssig sein.
So, dadurch, dass ich jetzt die passierten Tomaten genommen hab,
gehört zu Tomate immer ne Prise Zucker, auch wenn's jetzt ein herzhaftes Gericht ist.
Also nur so ne kleine Prise da rein geben und das ganze wirklich nur so ne Minute köcheln lassen,
dass es sich verbindet, dass es erhitzt wird.
Und dann ist unser leckeres türkisch angehauchtes Gericht auch schon fertig!
Dazu passt jetzt am besten Reis oder Kartoffeln, die passen auch sehr gut, ne?
Hack und Kartoffeln und Lauch? Perfekte Kombination!
Naja gut, wir essen heute Reis! Und das ganze Gericht hat auch nur 10-12min gedauert!
(H: Also wir Araber essen das sogar zum Frühstück!)
Ja das stimmt, das stimmt!
Araber essen immer sehr herzhaft zum Frühstück. Ja bei den Türken gibt's auch so
Menemen, das ist so ein Eiergericht.
Das ist dann auch mit ganz viel Peperoni und auch mit Lauch ab und zu, auch sehr lecker.
Ah ich merk schon, wir haben noch richtig  viele Videos vor uns!
(H: Also Menemen kannst du auf jeden Fall als nächstes machen!)
Das kann ich als nächstes machen!
Das typisch türkische, diese Eierspeise Menemen.
Wenn ihr das sehen möchtet oder generell auch mal Frühstücksrezepte:
einfach in die Kommentare reinschreiben!
So, wir gönnen uns das jetzt, wünschen euch auch einen guten Appetit wenn ihr es nachmacht.
Schaut unbedingt in die Videobeschreibung, da steht alles drin,
was ihr wissen möchtet. Ansonsten dem Video ein Däumchen nach oben da lassen
und meinen Kanal kostenlos hier unten abonnieren wenn ihr das nicht schon längst getan habt!
Und dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
(H: Krass wie schnell das ging!)
Das ging jetzt echt schnell! Voll gut!